eric toledano et olivier nakache
benjamin le sieur vincent cassel reda
kateb film absolument bouleversant je
vous laisse je laisse la parole vous
ressentez quoi ce soir encore une fois
une pluie de nominations pour l'un de
vos films
oui on est extrêmement fier heureux
d'être là avec ce film comporte en nous
depuis vraiment très longtemps donc on
est heureux d'être tous ensemble avec
vincent reza avec benjamin qu'elle n 20
cents voilà c'est une très grande fierté
on va profiter de cette soirée tous
ensemble alors reda kateb vincent cassel
vous jouez ces deux éducateurs hornu
hors du commun
je pense qu'il ya des films comme hors
norme qui laisse des traces forcément je
crois qu'on est on est marqué à vie
j'ai dit est ce qu'elle définit venez
venez reda et si je gêne je peux partir
quel accueil ya un truc qu'on a fait on
vous confirme les traces ouais ouais
tout à fait ouais non mais c'est vrai
que du coup d'être là aujourd'hui c'est
la prolongation d'une extraordinaire
aventure qu'on apprend à partager
ensemble les uns les autres
donc voilà
3 europe 1 vous avez découvert un
univers comme de nombreuses personnes
que vous connaissez pas je suppose moi
je connaissais pas grand-chose à
l'autisme et même après ce film je peux
pas dire que je connais grand chose en
fait
c'est tellement vaste et encore pardon
je pourrais pas prétendre en parler
vraiment je vous vois je vous demande en
train de partir charles aznavour il est
content parce qu'ils passent charlène
benjamin c'est me charles aznavour mais
mon cochambreur snav où il nous manque
il nous manque beaucoup
benjamin lecerf nommé dans la catégorie
meilleur raisin le rvr b c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on fait du cinéma je crois
c'est pour voir des des moments comme
celui-là et des acteurs comme benjamin
le surf que vous avez réussi a
brillamment dirigé d'un suis vraiment
bravo bravo pour tout ce que vous mettez
dans tous vos films
merci beaucoup merci laurie merci
beaucoup pour ça que je disais voilà on
c'était un vrai bonheur d'avoir ces deux
acteurs là qui sont derrière moi et
benjamins pour nous c'était un signe de
la combinaison parfaite pour porter la
lumière des gens qui s'occupent de de
ces jeunes autistes dans toute leur vie
donc on est extrêmement heureux fier
d'être là merci à tous les deux merci à
tous et bonne chance merci